all right one other thing i got to play
for you this is uh
uh
we could call it disappointing also not
really disappointing because it's
totally expected sam elliott's is of
course the famous iconic hollywood actor
and
a couple a few weeks ago we um gave him
some credit because he
was asked about this power of the dog
which is this artsy western
terrible boring movie doll very dull
movie that's i mean i i defy you to
watch the movie and make it through 15
minutes without falling asleep and it
was nominated for a bunch of awards and
everything and it's about a gay cowboy
and the critics are hailing it because
of the gay themes and everything else um
sam elliott in a podcast was asked about
this movie he gave an honest answer he
said he doesn't he doesn't like it he
doesn't you know he just doesn't he
doesn't need those kinds of themes in a
western he likes the more traditional
westerns that's his that was his honest
opinion about it
and um
of course people were very upset about
his honest opinions because he was asked
about his opinion of the movie
but just because as we've learned just
because you're asked about your opinion
of something that doesn't mean that
you're that you're actually entitled to
give your opinion
what they want to hear is you repeat the
accepted opinion
and pretend like it's your own whether
it is or not
and some people are very upset about
that and uh
and same elliot was on a panel a couple
days ago it was asked again and he is
now singing a little bit of a different
tune listen
yeah first don't go do a podcast whose
call letters are wtf
[Laughter]
that movie
stuck it struck a chord with me
and then
trying to
[Music]
tell the guy
the wtf guy how i felt about the film
i wasn't very articulate about it
i didn't articulate it very well
and i said some things that hurt people
i feel terrible about that
the gay community has been
incredible to me
my entire career
[Applause]
and i mean my entire career
from before i got started when i was in
this town
friends on every level
in every job description
up until today with my agent my dear
friend my agent of a number of years
and i'm sorry that i hurt any of those
friends
and someone that i loved
and anyone else
by
the words that i used
is he gonna cry it looks like he's about
to cry
i couldn't keep listening to the
watching the clips i don't know where
where it goes
it can't go anywhere good from here
it just goes to show look these these
are actors the characters they portray
on screen are fake of course and
oftentimes do not reflect who they
really are at all so sam elliott has
made a career playing these kind of
gritty
tough uh you know western badass type
figures
and here he is on a panel in hollywood
crying because people were had their
feelings hurt by his opinion
about a movie he's he's he's apologizing
to the people who he hurts
and those are people who were hurt by
sam elliott's opinion of power of the
dog
they were hurt because
sam elliott had an opinion about a movie
that they disagreed with
hurt
we never get any specifics on how this
like in what way were they hurt how
could they have been hurt by that
but they were so sam elliott grovels and
apologizes
uh it's just it's a damn shame
i mean he's old he's in his you know
he's in his 70s he's obviously rich he's
got plenty of money
um
and he has everything that he needs
to just throw up the middle finger
to all of the sensitive cry bullies
the not even really sensitive the
pretend sensitive cry bullies and say
you know what i don't care
but he's not going to do that because he
lives in hollywood and and this is how
he's been
he himself has been conditioned his
whole life
and it won't matter either
he is it doesn't you've already it's too
late sam you've revealed your actual
opinion about something
cat's out of the bag
and everyone knows the secret now they
know the secret that you actually have
your own opinions about things
and and god forbid you you you maybe
sometimes enjoy watching movies
where
um
there's there's not uh lgbt ideology
being being uh shoved in your face every
second like you'd sometimes prefer to
watch movies without that god forbid so
you've already revealed that they know
it now
and you can cry and apologize all you
want it's not gonna change
could have kept your dignity
decided to give it up and you get
nothing in return
same old story well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt wall show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content